abdul qadir juma is a uiga poet
and translator or he used to be
his brother mama jaan says he now works
in a forced labor camp in china
making headphones without knowing maybe
i might
i might be using one of those headphones
that headphones that my brother
is is kind of forced to make it made i
mean
it is unbearable feeling it's unbearable
campaigners have called on international
brands to cut ties to chinese suppliers
allegedly using the forced labor of
uyghurs so
basically these so-called
factories kind of uh prison-like
factories so they kind of live on their
own so
uh and sometimes if the officials are
good to them they're allowed to leave at
least once a week
around a million uyga people are
estimated to have been sent to camps in
xinjiang in the northwest of china
the region is kept under an iron grip as
we found when we reported with heavy
surveillance last year
the chinese government says the camps
are voluntary education centers
and are necessary to fight extremism but
activists say that many people have now
been transferred from camps to work
facilities
especially in the cotton industry
chinese state media insists work like
this
is part of a poverty alleviation
programme
more than 180 civil rights organizations
from around the world
are urging western brands to stop
sourcing cotton textiles and garments
from xinjiang
within 12 months
mahmut lives in exile in the uk where
she works as an activist
china is benefiting from the forced
labor
economically and when we
live in west when we are buying these
products allowing companies who
whose supply chain are
contaminated by this forced labor
and it is wrong china has recently come
under
increased pressure over its treatment of
the uyghurs with the british foreign
secretary dominic raab accusing the
country of gross and egregious human
rights abuses
it is high time for those who have
experienced the camps first hand
like cyril
[Music]
[Music]
the chinese government has previously
called such allegations
sheer lies many uighurs though believe
their experience is finally being
dragged out from the dark
and into the light tom cheshire sky news
beijing